have you heard of daniel dennett's
quinine qualia argument
if not we can move on
well i read it
years ago and
maybe i'm not doing justice to it but
the way i understood it
you can check and see if this is
accurate
is as an argument
saying that the notion of qualia
plays no
clear
and constructive role
in our
account of the world including our
experience so we can dispense with it
uh
because there's no theory of quality
basically actually as far as i recall
you can check and see
he didn't discuss
the one
careful systematic
theory that uses qualia
namely
nelson goodman's
major work structure of appearance
which was
an attempt to
redo
what carnap had done earlier in his
lucas off their build
cornap had tried to construct
lucas alfpower logical construction to
the world
based on
objects
and goodman
redid it
not talking about the world but just
about appearance
on the basis of qualia
and that's a systematic theory that uses
the notion qualia with a lot of
interesting results
so within
i don't know what bennett would say
about this i don't think he discussed it
it's the one
case that i know of a
serious theoretical
construction based on quality and has
i think quite interesting results
but it's the structure of appearance
remember actually i knew goodman pretty
well i was a student of his he had in
mind
a second volume
which would be the structure of
the world
never got to that
it was very hard to even get to the
structure of appearance
have you read daniel dennett's
consciousness explained book
and if so do you feel like it was
explained consciousness has been
explained
a lot of
clever observations
it's interesting to read i think it
leaves
consciousness where it was
in fact the question of explaining
consciousness
is a very curious one
i mean these it's a modern concern
until pretty recently
consciousness was not a major issue in
philosophy
uh when it entered
at first during the
great modern early modern period
the notion consciousness was used for
self-consciousness awareness of
one's own mind the
modern problem was called by david
chalmers the hard problem that's
basically the last century
as far as i can see the
best approach to it
to the so-called problem
was actually given by bertrand russell a
century ago
i
pointed out
i think correctly
that our
what we are most confident about
is our own experience
the rest of their intellectual efforts
or attempts to
make some sense of it
science for example
is an effort to see if you can
make some sense of
consciousness conscious experience
and he pointed out as well that
we would like to explain
consciousness in material terms
but the problem is we have no idea what
material is for example we don't know
whether
all matter has consciousness
arthur eddington his friend and
colleague scientist pointed out that
we don't know that
atoms don't have consciousness we don't
have a clear enough understanding of the
basis of it
so as
in recent work
galen straws and
fine young philosophers
picked this up and pointed out i think
correctly that it's not consciousness
this has to be explained
that we understand very well
we can describe it in extensive detail
what we don't understand is matter
so when you talk about
explaining consciousness trying to
account for it in material terms
the roadblock is we don't know what
material terms are
in fact that's true
you can pick up a journal of
quantum mechanics recent journal
somebody just sent me one
which is symposium of
leading quantum physicists
trying to figure out what a particle is
they don't know
we know we have to postulate particles
but we don't know what they are
the same
matter is a very
i mean there was a concept of matter
in the
early modern scientific revolution
so-called mechanical philosophy but that
was
shattered by newton
and though he didn't believe it
and regarded it as observed but
science has since accepted it
and that leaves us without a
clear notion of what matters
consciousness we understand as much as
you can understand anything